if you're trying to write copy one of
the things that I think through as a
framework is what I call plus plus minus
minus self friends enemies what are all
the ways that I can say more good plus
plus right you get more of these good
things in your life on the flip side
it's how can we get less of these
negative things in your life and then I
frame that within the perspective of
yourself how your friends will see you
and then how your enemies will perceive
those pluses and those minuses because
it's not always just convincing them
about their benefits but how their
benefits will be perceived through their
competition how their benefits will be
perceived through their wife if all of a
sudden you being successful your wife
sees you a different way that might be a
much greater benefit than actually being
successful and you crushing your
competition might be more of a benefit
to you than actually being successful
which oftentimes status and how we are
perceived in the eyes of others is more
important than the thing we did itself